all right we talked a bit about
whether or not a coach is going to be
fired during the season will there be
one fired by week eight or week nine the
over under we had at 0.5 and that led us
to start speculating on the guys who may
be under the most pressure and you made
a good point a lot of the bad teams have
new coaches right so how much pressure
really is there who stands out to you i
know there's one guy from me who is head
and shoulders above the rest as it
relates to full season pressure and
possibly being out of a job at the end
of the year and your guest you're saying
jason jason garrett yeah i mean jason
garrett i think is the guy that pops to
me as well you know yeah he's going into
the last year of his contract we know
jerry jones wants playoff wins and he
thinks this is a talented roster and and
certainly a super bowl caliber football
team so yeah i think that i if you made
me look at one guy who's under the most
pressure in all of football i i would
say it starts right there uh with him
after that
then it becomes interesting the
conversation you know where where do you
think it goes who's the next guy in line
for you where you go pressure is it pat
shurmur because of the giants i know you
mentioned it's only been that show he's
only been there this is second i know i
i'm with you but i think mike zimmer's
under pressure you think zimmer's
underpriced i mean he got an extension
he didn't get an extension they picked
up the option to extend his contract by
a year so if he would get fired after
this year if they'd move on and go in a
different direction because the team
goes four and 12 and kirk cousins is a
disaster and they decide to clean house
i'm not saying they will yeah but you're
under pressure to you're under pressure
to take this team and get this team to
the playoffs or there could be some
tough questions i think he's a guy who
could be in some degree of of of uh
jeopardy yeah okay and then i guess if
we're going to put them there then we're
talking pressure mike tomlin's probably
another guy right if it's a disaster in
pittsburgh yeah this the fans aren't
going to stand for it yeah right i mean
do you think mike tomlin has to make the
playoffs
to save his job or continue to work
there i don't think he has to make the
playoffs but he better be better than
six and ten yeah six and ten or worse
and i think he could be in serious
trouble yeah and it'd be interesting to
see i mean it really would be freddie
kitchens is under a ton of pressure even
though he's unlikely to get fired here's
the thing yeah if the g if the bear if
the
giant one giants then bears browns third
time was a charm the browns just flat
out stink this year it's going to be
kitchen's fault and as the season
unfolds you're going to have agents who
are reaching out to the browns saying
you know if you decide to make a change
i got the right guy i got you know i got
to yeah coach baker mayfield i got a guy
who'd love to coach baker mayfield i'm
not going to name names here but you
that happens yeah sure and that could
put the idea in jimmy haslam's head you
know what yeah i've fired a lot of guys
quickly but you know we gave this
freddie kitchen's guy a chance it really
hasn't worked maybe it's time to swing
for the fences we have the players now
we have to upgrade the coach right yeah
and uh it wouldn't surprise me no i i
hear you i mean he is certainly under
pressure but that team and everybody's
you know looking at them because they're
all excited about it i get it but yeah i
mean there's a lot about you guys what
about your guy john gruden yeah i
pressure definitely you know i think
it's interesting at least we're saying
pressure though it's not hot seat i
don't that's where i'm happy we're not
well they're all under pressure well yes
they're all under pressure but those
guys i do think have a little bit more
of uh you know a microscope on them than
maybe the other teams in football both
is probably going to think i think
everybody except bill belichick could
have a bad enough season this year to
get fired you think so every coach yeah
mcveigh could okay
owen 16. if the rams somehow somewhere
would go on 16 would would make vegas no
no he would not i don't think maybe it's
better but either okay uh
yeah i'd there'd be a mutual party what
about andy reid
oh and 16 but that's the thing it's
never going to i know i know yeah i but
like if they were maybe maybe i think so
yeah i feel like those guys are kind of
untouchable i i think belichick mcveigh
what about doug peterson
yeah he's untouchable too i think still
at this point yeah 16 is a tough one to
come back from it's just hard to
conceptualize it because it's not these
guys aren't going to no they're not